simple has had a lot of issues with
Counterstrike 2 and he hasn't been shy
about voicing his complaints so much so
that valve actually reached out to him
after he called the game [__] but simple
straight up ignored valve and people
aren't too happy about
[Music]
it IEM Sydney CS 2's first ever tier one
landan just wrapped up over the weekend
and it was awesome sure there were a few
minor hiccups here and there but things
were relatively smooth and the Grand
Final saw phase and complexity face off
with FaZe winning what might end up
being their swan song Oh and the show
match got really really weird what the
fck why are there so many big [__]
everywhere however the biggest Story
coming out of the weekend had nothing to
do with the actual tournament at all it
was about simple a guy who wasn't even
there why well heading into the playoffs
this clip went viral have you talked
with Val about CS2 man they WR me in
Twitter and they asked me what the
issues you know what I did I never
answer them back how can you ask me what
the issue if the whole internet whole
Twitter writing about issues you don't
see theing issue what you don't see it
yes simple suggested that valve could
simply find all the answers to their
problems on Twitter and then proceeded
to leave them on r
yes simple ignored valve the company
known for not talking to anyone now for
context simple like many other Pros
hasn't been having the best of time
transitioning to this new era of
Counterstrike stupid game man how I'm
blocking with this jump how I'm blocking
with this man why did you change
textures the normal one as a result the
goat has been pretty critical of the
game including this tweet where he said
don't play this game right now wait for
updates now because of this tweet and
since he's one of the most influential
players of all time valve reached out to
him to hopefully talk over some of his
complaints with CS2 simple ghosted valve
and then pretty much told them to f off
in this clip where he honestly seemed
pretty insulted by the DM and listen I
do get the frustration simple like many
other Pros has a lot on the line he's
not here to be valve's play tester
however not everyone was on simple's
side for this one a lot of community
members felt as if he was just being a
crybaby many believe that simple was
given a unique opportunity to have this
one-on-one conversation with valve but
he threw it away just to be Petty help
some went so far as to say that simple
was being entitled for not wanting to
help the game he owes his life and
paycheck to that being said there were
still some who were on his side agreeing
that valve could easily find what's
wrong with the game just by looking
online now my honest opinion two things
can be true at the same time for
starters does this needlessly make
simple look like a dick yes of course it
does but honestly he's always been like
this and probably doesn't care my guess
on which side you Tak in this beef
depends on how you already felt about
the guy now could simple provide a much
more succinct review of all the issues
he faces yes of course he's a
professional player and telling valve to
look on Twitter is obviously ridiculous
this app is a cesspool there are
hundreds of posts a minute and most of
them are probably non-issues or other
random [__] asking valve to sort
through it would be a bad use of time
that being said I am pretty confident
that valve is well aware of the game's
issues or at least 99% of the things
that simple or any other Pro would bring
up this was clearly valve trying to do a
little bit of damage control simple the
best player in the world isn't happy and
they probably don't want him feeling
like he's being left high and dry I
think dming him is the least that they
could do and I'm sure that simple is far
from the only person valve has reached
out to now does simple owe valve or the
community something for making him who
he is today and practically signing his
checks well I don't know about all that
but what I do know is that a single
response from simple probably wasn't
going to fix the game but that's it
right simple was just being simple as
per usual and we can just move on with
our lives well not quite some think this
goes a bit deeper as I mentioned earlier
simple did not attend IM IM Sydney
forcing their coach blade to play in his
place some felt that given the timing of
his game tweet this was a form of
protest there was also some weird
reports claiming that simple was
actually drunk and missed his flight but
simple clapped back against these
so-called insiders saying that they were
full of sh regardless it was later
cleared up by multiple sources that
simple was just having Visa issues and
that any other theory was complete
[__] that being said it hasn't
stopped anyone from working working on
their conspiracy theories especially
after simple said on stream that he was
only hopefully going to be at the next
event is simple having personal issues
is na'vi secretly trying to get rid of
him does simple hate the game so much
that he's refusing to play at
events I don't think so Visa issues are
complicated and they do not discriminate
even if you might be the greatest CS
player of all time still with that in
mind I would like to hear what you guys
think about this whole mess is there a
larger conspiracy does simple o valve a
response or is this just the start of a
new era of another toxic simple
Demitri's immediate response to simple
not replying to valve was that oh yeah
this sh based and I do kind of get it
it's just like like I said like he's not
their play tester he has other to worry
about and it does take a lot of brain
power for him to like you know sit down
or for anyone to sit down and like
actually like write about your issues
and if you're not a developer it just
might seem like well what the you know
what the issues are and I do agree they
know what the issues are did he need to
respond like that probably not